y
[Música]
en francia varios miembros de la actual
y del anterior gobierno incluido el ex
primer ministro edward philip fueron
objeto este jueves de registros
judiciales en sus oficinas y en sus
domicilios en el ámbito de la
investigación abierta por la gestión de
la pandemia tenemos reporte desde parís
una gran preocupación genera la pandemia
en europa dice la ms la segunda ola está
obligando a varios países a endurecer
medidas francia aprobó un toque de queda
nocturno en parís alemania polonia y
croacia tuvieron un máximo récord de
casos desde que se declaró la pandemia
en marzo y londres prohibir a reunirse
bajo techo a personas de diferentes
hogares
donald trump y joe biden mantendrán un
duelo por la audiencia respondiendo
preguntas de los votantes en prime time
en el día propuesto para el debate
virtual del que el presidente rechazó
participar mientras los estadounidenses
marcan un ritmo récord de sufragio
anticipado y los estados siguen abriendo
las urnas ambos candidatos se enfocan en
estados clave como florida y iowa
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' ya todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
alan austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en francia donde la policía ha
registrado las casas y oficinas del
actual y del anterior gobierno entre
ellos varios políticos como el ex primer
ministro de dwight phillips el actual
ministro de salud y su antecesora como
parte de una investigación judicial
sobre el manejo gubernamental de la
pandemia del cob y 19 es por ello que
enlazamos a parís con natalia ruiz quien
se encuentra frente al palacio de
justicia donde están las oficinas de la
comisión de la corte que está al frente
de esta investigación
natalia te saludamos por allá en la
capital danos más detalles de estos
registros qué es lo que está sucediendo
en la capital francesa
y muy buenos días pues todo esto forma
parte de una investigación judicial que
se abrió el pasado 7 de julio aquí en
francia por parte del tribunal de
justicia de la república este es el
tribunal la instancia que está
habilitada para investigar a los
miembros del gobierno se abrió el 7 de
julio en realidad desde el comienzo de
la pandemia se recibieron cerca de 90
demandas pero solamente nueve de ellas
fueron encontradas procedentes y todas
éstas forman parte digamos de todo un
paquete de estas demandas que en
realidad quieren saber si los miembros
del gobierno estaban al tanto de medidas
sanitarias que debían a tomar para
luchar contra la pandemia y que en
realidad no lo hicieron en caso de que
se pruebe esto pues esto es considerado
un delito penal aquí en francia y pues
esto puede llevar a penas de hasta dos
años de cárcel y 30 mil euros de multa
así que eso es lo que están realizando
la investigación que está realizando las
autoridades actualmente
natalidad más detalles de quiénes son
otros altos funcionarios y quiénes están
detrás de las demandas
pues lo que usted decía el del ex primer
ministro edouard fil y también de olivia
de ajo pero también está la ex portavoz
del gobierno y veten día y aún así el
profesor diagonal salomón quien es el
director de sanidad aquí en francia
quienes están detrás de estas demandas
bueno en realidad son varias personas no
solamente de digamos particulares sino
también asociaciones de médicos incluso
hay un sindicato de policía que está
detrás de estas demandas y pues uno de
los abogados a cargo a cargo de esto
pues decía se felicitaba de la celeridad
con la que la justicia está obrando en
pues buscando haciendo esta
investigación y esperando pues saber
sobre todo el contenido de los
computadores que hoy en día pues ya
están en manos de los investigadores y
que pueden determinar qué comunicaciones
se hicieron entre el ministro de salud y
la presidencia así como de sanidad y el
ministerio de salud sobre todo en cuanto
a la cantidad de material de protección
para el personal sanitario y también el
número de existencias de mascarillas
algo que ha generado polémica desde el
comienzo de esta situación aquí en
francia
gracias natalia ruiz por tu reporte
seguiremos pendientes contigo de esta
noticia que está en desarrollo en parís
y seguimos en este país y es que después
de una primera ola que dejó más de 30
mil víctimas mortales francia se
enfrenta a un fuerte resurgimiento del
coronavirus un tercio de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos del país están
ocupadas por pacientes graves de kobe 19
el presidente de manuel macrón anunció a
partir del sábado y por al menos cuatro
semanas un toque de queda entre las
nueve de la noche y las seis de la
mañana en el siguiente informe les
traemos las reacciones desde la capital
francesa una de las nuevas ciudades
afectadas
a partir de este sábado 20 millones de
franceses ya no podrán ir al cine al
teatro ni a los restaurantes después de
las nueve de la noche con el
resurgimiento de la epidemia de
coronavirus en francia el presidente
manuel marco anunció un toque de queda
desde las nueve de la noche hasta las
seis de la mañana durante al menos
cuatro semanas
personalmente trabajo desde casa así que
confieso que las salidas eran mi única
alegría en la vida suave mismo del
servicio además de parís y su región se
trata de ocho ciudades importantes es
decir casi un tercio de la población es
la primera vez que una proporción tan
grande de habitantes está bajo toque de
queda desde la segunda guerra mundial yo
lo veo un poco injusto porque por un
lado egoístamente nos decimos a nosotros
mismos que no somos nosotros los que
estamos en peligro
y pasando todos somos como yo también
estoy encantado de pasar un tiempo en
casa en primer lugar por mi trabajo pero
no me gusta que me digan que hacer
el presidente francés también anunció
ayudas adicionales para los sectores
económicos más golpeados por el toque de
queda y que se van a ver aún más
afectados como el sector de los
restaurantes juntos como 7 30pm va a ser
la última toma de pedido como aquí la
gente no come a las 7 va a ser un poco
difícil para las medidas fueran
criticadas por algunos representantes
locales electos pero la alcaldesa de
parís respaldo por su parte la decisión
del presidente prometiendo apoyo al
mundo de la cultura en la capital y es
que la evolución de la pandemia en
europa provoca una gran preocupación
para lo ms y la unión europea pide a los
estados miembros hacer lo necesario para
evitar un confinamiento general la
segunda bola está golpeando al
continente tan o más fuerte que la
primera obligando a varios países a
endurecer las restricciones esto previo
al comienzo del invierno en el
hemisferio norte alemania registró su
mayor número de casos de coronavirus en
24 horas londres pasará a un nivel más
estricto de restricción
para contener la pandemia los
legisladores británicos señalaron la
prohibición a partir de la medianoche de
este viernes de las reuniones bajo techo
entre personas que no viven en el mismo
hogar tras reportar un récord de más de
8000 nuevos contagios polonia está
acelerando la formación de enfermeras y
evaluando la creación de hospitales
militares de campaña mientras tanto
croacia también marcó un nuevo récord
desde que se declaró la pandemia en
marzo 748 nuevos casos este máximo
supone un gran salto de contagios
diarios respecto al último máximo
anterior de 500 242
mientras que en eeuu vamos con la
carrera electoral el presidente retomó
la campaña electoral del lunes en
florida y volverá hoy a este estado para
un programa televisivo donald trump y su
rival demócrata joe biden mantendrán
este jueves un duelo por la audiencia
pues ambos se someterán a las preguntas
de los votantes en prime time de la nfc
para el republicano y de la abc para el
demócrata el evento sustituye el debate
virtual planteado por la comisión
electoral y del que trump rechazó
participar ayer tres estados más
abrieron las urnas para la votación
anticipada kansas rhode island y
tennessee el martes se vieron largas
filas fuera de los locales de votación
en los estados de texas y georgia yobái
de no tuvo actos de campaña de ayer tras
pasar por florida el martes mientras que
el presidente celebró un acto en el
aeropuerto de iowa un estado clave
electoral
así que les digo desde iowa que ustedes
son un estado muy poderoso políticamente
son un gran estado para mí grande de
corazón tienen una tremenda influencia
un tremendo poder y nunca me han
defraudado a las voces de los musulmanes
estadounidenses son importantes para
nuestra comunidad y nuestro país sé que
no siempre han recibido el respeto o la
representación que se merecen hemos
visto lo que sucede cuando un presidente
aviva las llamas crímenes de odio en
marcha más niños intimidados en las
escuelas un aumento de la intolerancia
anti musulmana esto no es lo que somos
faltan sólo tres días para las
elecciones generales en bolivia se
elegirán diversas autoridades entre
ellas el presidente seis candidatos en
contienda pero tres son los más
opcionados luís arse del movimiento al
socialismo más partido del ex presidente
evo morales carlos meza de comunidad
ciudadana ex presidente del país y
segundo en las preferencias y los
fernando camacho de creemos quién
y labró su popularidad en las protestas
que causaron la renuncia de evo morales
en 2019 es por ello que nos acompaña
desde la paz nuestra corresponsal mary
bach buenos días por ella mary bolivia
repite la elección tras los comicios
anulados el año pasado tras denuncias de
presunto fraude que obligaron a morales
a renunciar ha bajado el clima de
confrontación a pocas horas de la nueva
zona hola que tal buenos días
evidentemente en bolivia rige una veda
electoral entre hoy jueves y el domingo
y por tanto se percibe una calma en las
diferentes ciudades del país sin embargo
debo comentarles que el alto comisionado
de naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos ha detectado más de 40 episodios
de violencia en la campaña electoral en
bolivia desde septiembre hasta la fecha
y eso se debe a que los partidos
políticos por ejemplo se han agredido
entre sí han quemado sus casas de
campaña no ha sido violencia que ha
llegado a hechos mayores pero que sí ha
generado un ambiente de malestar en el
país por otro lado les comento que las
últimas horas la ciudadanía sobre todo
en la
más está haciendo largas filas en los
surtidores de gasolina para llegar
llenar los tanques de los vehículos y
además está recurriendo a los centros de
abasto para comprar muchos alimentos
pues existe el temor de que después de
las elecciones hubiera algún partido que
no quiera reconocer los resultados y se
pueda generar violencia en ese marco los
organismos internacionales que están
observando las elecciones han pedido a
los partidos que reconozcan los
resultados y que garanticen la paz en
bolivia cómo está el proceso de
transparencia electoral mary quienes
estarán vigilando los comicios estas van
a ser unas elecciones muy observadas tal
vez las más observadas de la historia de
bolivia después del presunto fraude que
se ha cometido el año pasado existen por
ejemplo misiones de observación de la
organización de estados américanos que
ha acreditado a 40 expertos de
diferentes nacionalidades está la unión
europea está también el centro cárter y
como nunca se ha establecido una red
enorme de ciudadanos que van a observar
las elecciones por ejemplo existe una
iniciativa que se llama bolivia observa
y que aglutina a 2.500 ciudadanos que
van a estar mirando la transparencia de
este proceso
muy bien meriva que muchas gracias por
tu reporte la corresponsal de france 24
en bolivia o nosotros temas y es que
desde el incendio en el campo de memoria
más de 2300 migrantes han sido evacuados
hacia europa continental en operaciones
organizadas por el gobierno griego la
oficina de la onu para los refugiados y
la oficina europea de asilo se trata
sobre todo de personas vulnerables en el
último capítulo de nuestra serie sobre
el incendio de lesbos nuestra enviada de
especial eric a olavarría presenció una
de estas evacuaciones y al final si
alguno no se van quiero que salgan de
aquí y cerremos la puerta del campo con
111 migrantes han sido elegidos para
irse del nuevo campo de karate les han
avisado hace sólo algunas horas
estoy verdaderamente feliz porque voy a
dejar este campo y me voy a un lugar
mejor no voy a vivir más en esta miseria
ni ver más incendios
estoy muy feliz de irme de aquí las voy
a echar de menos
gracias adiós
[Música]
pero la felicidad no es para todos los
miembros de algunas familias deben
separarse de mis hermanos se van con mis
padres al continente pero yo me tengo
que quedar aquí porque tengo un timbre
de rojo que me impide salir mi abuela se
queda para cuidarme
llamamos al jefe del campo y él decidió
que ali mohamed se quede aquí con su
abuela
qué más podemos hacer mi niño se queda
aquí
después de meses e incluso años les gos
estos migrantes son enviados a grecia
continental para vivir en unos
departamentos financiados por la unión
europea aunque no saben dónde van no
puede ser peor que moria al que todos
llaman el infierno no sé dónde vamos
quizás a salónica o creta en todo caso
espero que sea mejor que este campo
a bordo de este ferry estos 111
migrantes dejan atrás el infierno de
moria pero el camino para ellos está
lejos de terminar ahora entrarán por
primera vez en europa continental donde
deben retomar su demanda de asilo sólo
una vez resuelta podrán comenzar a
pensar en un futuro
[Música]
llegamos al final de esta emisión pero
no me quiero despedir sin antes
ofrecerles nuestras plataformas
digitales en nuestro sitio web france24
o puntocom le tenemos dos noticias
principales y un análisis muy
interesante de las elecciones
estadounidenses lo que les comentábamos
de los estados clave porque florida es
tan importante en las elecciones
presidenciales de eeuu
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
les agradecemos mucho su compañía siga
con nosotros en francés 24
[Música]